et pour en parler nous sommes avertis
rival un avocat au barreau de paris et
spécialiste des questions numériques à
thierry va là bonjour je vous remercie
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
on vient d'entendre ces paroles l'animal
anonymat est une honte sur les réseaux
sociaux
nous devons mettre à jour nos processus
judiciaire les mots de cédric oe2 et de
richard ferrand qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
c'est ridicule c'est ridicule et ça
démontre bien là l'écart qu'il ya entre
ces gens qui ne connaissent absolument
pas le monde numérique et la réalité de
ce que on vit aujourd'hui avec internet
et les réseaux sociaux l'anonymat ça
n'existe pas sur internet
combien de fois faudra-t-il le répéter
le pseudonymat existe revanche et permet
à tout un chacun de pouvoir choisir de
s'exprimer sous ce pseudonyme se donne
ima anonymat qu'elle dise distinction
qu'elle 1,5 sion c'est que pseudonyme ah
bon vous l'appelez choupinou 123 et vous
signez souhaitez vous pouvez très bien
être retrouvés sur les réseaux sociaux
de manière extrêmement facile il suffit
de demander votre identifiant aux
plateformes qui qui vous héberge c'est
tout à fait tout à fait normal et
l'anonymat de toute façon c'est la même
chose vous avez chaque empreinte
numérique vous mettez sur la toile et
indélébile ll est fixé avec une adresse
qu'on appelle adresse ip il suffit que
la police judiciaire comptant un héros
qu'il cherche
et c'est effectivement qui se trouvent
des adresses adresses ip et on retrouve
facilement votre ordinateur
donc aujourd'hui ce que vous nous dites
c'est que au fond l'arsenal juridique
existe viendront lutter contre
l'anonymat raconte complètement et le
petit de neema permet en plus de pouvoir
permettre à des personnes qui ne
pourraient pas s'exprimer autrement
je pense à des des problèmes d'identité
sexuelle à des problèmes de religieux à
des problèmes de simplement de
profession des militaires qui ne peut
passer créer des magistrats ils sont
source de nivat ya aucun problème des
avocats aussi moi je signe sur twitter
sous le nom mais c'est un choix d'autres
enfants différemment ce que vous me
dites c'est que ça permet aussi de
soulever des problématiques de notre
société
bien évidemment et vouloir
supprimer l'anonymat soit disant ça veut
dire essayer de relier sur la liberté
d'expression une nouvelle fois c'est
encore des tentatives que je
qualifierais malheureusement de
liberticide par rapport à c'est un
discours encore de buzz de vouloir
frapper
on a aujourd'hui tout ce qu'il faut pour
effectivement permettre de réguler
internet comme ils le comme il le faut
et il n'y a pas de ya pas deux il n'y a
pas de difficultés mais ce que cet
arsenal juridique aujourd'hui il est
suffisamment utilisé ou connus par la
morale et non c'est une excellente
question et c'est exactement là où le
bât blesse
par exemple pour revenir sur ce qu'on
appelle le revenge forme ou le porno
divulgation dont on a beaucoup parlé
avec affaire rio il y a eu simplement 91
condamnation camp en 2017 et 192
d'après les statistiques en 2018 s'est
pas beaucoup pourquoi c'est pas beaucoup
parce que déjà il n'y a pas beaucoup de
gens qui portent plainte et que les
plaintes lorsqu'elles sont en essai de
l'es2 les données faire elles ne sont
pas forcément toujours prive donc il ya
près de pédagogie par par rapport non
seulement aux officiers de police
judiciaire qui doivent traiter ce type
de dossier tout le monde ne s'appelle
pas monsieur griveaux qui lui a bien sûr
été très bien pu avoir sa plainte
immédiatement transformées en
information judiciaire fait exceptionnel
finalement la rapidité du traitement
voilà mes cils ça devrait être pour tout
un chacun est derrière des moyens et
parce que c'est les moyens dont on
manque est également une pédagogie par
rapport aux magistrats par rapport aux
juges qui souvent parce que le revenir
sur le rivage par l'article 226 2 1 du
code pénal c'est deux ans de prison 60
mille euros d'amande et jamais ces
condamnations de son prononcé
on a des petites amendes on a des
petites condamnations éventuellement
avec du sursis si elle récidive si vous
avez un casier judiciaire donc en
réalité et frapper plus fort ça aurait
peut-être un moyen peut-être plus
pédagogique la jeu
pour dissuader les gens de conduire de
manière un civil sur eux sur internet
donc pour vous c'est pas une question
juridique mais elle est davantage
d'ordre pédagogique voire éducatif pour
les plus pour les plus jeunes bien
évidemment internet n'est pas une zone
de non droit comme on l'entend trop trop
trop souvent aujourd'hui tout ça est
complètement complètement balisé alors
on a eu en plus une loi la loi de madame
avia on avait dit jean mi melle sur ce
plateau pis que pendre parce que elle va
aussi malheureusement en mettant les
clés du camion dans l'est la régulation
des dégâts femme peut être relié
également sur la liberté d'expression
on l'a vu aujourd'hui avec par exemple
le compte twitter du syndicat des
davosiens j'allais y venir justement qui
a été suspendu parce que alors par
twitter par l'algorithme est alors il a
été rétabli
heureusement il a fallu un tollé général
pour pour le faire établir tout ça
pourquoi parce que l'algorithme de
twitter a considéré qu'il était un spam
c'est ce qui est ce qu'ils prétendent
c'était l'excès de l'explication qui a
été donnée parce que c'est vrai qu'il a
été surpris mais au fond sans aucune
explication voit on voit bien que la
régulation il ya un problème dans cette
modération de de parler parler parler
parler gafa par facebook par twitter et
twitter est pas forcément le meilleur
élève de la de la classe mais lorsqu'on
va mettre des amendes extrêmement
importantes telles que la loi et via ce
propos de le faire quand elle sera voté
en deuxième lecture par l'assemblée donc
là on aura quand même peut-être une
tendance des deux de ces de ses
plateformes à vouloir et enlever
immédiatement tout rue contenu soit
disant problématique là où il y aura
ouvertement du sexuel de l'homophobe de
bon ça ça posera pas difficulté mais
pour tous les goûts grill là le tweet du
du staff du syndicat des avocats
totalement inimaginable qu'on est qu'on
ait eu une suspension que justin brook
est le rôle donc
de ses gaffes un de ces géants du
numérique dans le contrôle il doit y
avoir un cahier des charges très clair
et puis le reste on laisse je crois
qu'aujourd'hui comme les allemands l'ont
fait avec la loi next dégaine à trois
ans on a on a et facebook d'ailleurs ce
qui est parfaitement parfaitement
réguler donc il ya des bons élèves des
moins bons élèves il faut simplement
refaire un petit peu de pression sur les
sur les ai discuté avec les réseaux
sociaux avec en tout cas les plateformes
et puis surtout faire la pédagogie
derrière avec avec avec les gens on se
trompe on ne se conduit pas sur twitter
comment se conduire est pas dans la rue
effectivement pour reprendre les termes
de ces tricots mais franchement vouloir
supprimer l'anonymat
c'est totalement déraisonnable et
liberticide notant qu' internet n'a pas
de frontières alors l'arsenal juridique
qui existe pour la france qu'on est il
finalement à l'étranger par exemple aux
états unis on n'a pas du tout les mêmes
références culturelles est là le premier
amendement qui autorise une liberté
d'expression totale donc bien évidemment
il n'y a pas du tout la même sensibilité
et c'est bien souvent derrière des des
appréciations américaine que twitter ou
facebook qui sont en californie vont
nous dire mais attendez moi j'applique
la loi américaine epa la loi française
donc oui vous avez tout à fait raison il
ya ce problème de frontière
voilà on peut appliquer en france à sa
forme de choses allaient retrouver des
sites internet ailleurs et d'ailleurs on
le voit bien d'ailleurs dans la sphère
griot c'est pas les réseaux sociaux qui
sont en compte en cause c'est un site
internet de monsieur polanski identifié
revendiquer les minima n'aurait
absolument rien changé
injustement alors pour conclure c'est
donc l'affairé rivaux qui a questionné
les politiques sur la question de
l'anonymat
or quand on regarde c'est vrai qu'il ya
pas de personnes anonymes dans ce
dossier grives et donc on comment on
peut expliquer finalement que les
politiques souhaitent s'emparer de cette
question maintenant euros je crois qu'il
est aussi un petit peu pour faire pour
faire 2
démagogie moi je vois ça un peu pour
faire le buzz et parce qu'il est
toujours très très bon de dire oh là là
on fait haro sur sur internet et
l'anonymat c'est terrible en fait non il
faut simplement essayer d'apprendre et
c'est dommage pour les gens qui votent
des lois sur sur internet ils ont voté
la loi fait que nous il ya il ya
quelques mois ils sont mignons
d'ailleurs monsieur legendre semble
l'avoir oublié puisqu'il avait pris
comme capcom comme point d'appui qu'il
fallait une voie ferrée qui use pour
empêcher une nouvelle affaire rio est
totalement déraisonnable le pseudonymat
aujourd'hui c'est le meilleur garantie
de la vie privée des gens merci beaucoup
tirent ivala d'avoir accepté notre
invitation je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat au barreau de paris spécialiste
des questions numériques
merci